Italians can't do dessert gelato
fantastic gelato it's ice cream it's
gelato yeah it's ice cream the ice cream
is ice cream and then you have July
I got it I'm not making the food I'm
eating the food you could
not take an ice cream in gelato if I put
them in front of you like that yes
put a spoon in both you would Japan oh
some delicious ice cream you eat with
your hands what are you you're sucker on
your thumb half the time you feel less
wrong about what you're saying by doing
this I'm just saying that's my knee
because you felt it right you had to
apply pressure because you know you've
eaten your fingernails most of your life
and you're like this is delicious thank
you so much you can just put your fist
in it
and then afterwards slurp it up okay
this guy's not gonna be able to tell the
difference this guy's not gonna be able
to tell the difference there's no [__]
away I can't tell the difference I just
want to laugh there's no way